How has motherhood affected...
I mean, I'm sure you're a real lion, I'm guessing.
Yeah, I'm a mama bear when it come
to my family and my child.
But I think that I'm very nurturing to begin with.
And I think motherhood has ignited even more
that protection to women.
I think that when you have a child,
whether it's a little boy, a little girl,
I think education is the foundation
of who they are when they're adulthoods.
And so we have to teach them how to,
that it's okay to learn about sexual education,
but also, it's okay to learn
about healthy relationships, right?
That starts at home, and it starts at school.
And that's exactly what my foundation do.
I reach out to the communities
and I reach out to college and universities
by doing the speeches and forums that I do,
educating them about sexual abuse
and consent, domestic abuse.
So if we're your audience, or we're your daughter,
or we're some of the people you're trying to reach out to,
how did you make different choices
with your current partner?
And what do you teach people about what to find acceptable
and not acceptable?
I think it all becomes with education, again.
And this is the very essence of being a person
who before you judge somebody, you have to educate there.
There's a difference between an educated judgment
versus an uneducated judgment.
So before, there's a lot of...
And I told even my daughter, so when I go to school
and I said, "Look, I mean, this is very important
for you to learn."
And also, to learn to trust people
because you cannot live your life without trusting anybody.
I think there's a very fine line
when you are about to judge something
or somebody that you hear because the news are an opinion
of a person who's writing the news, not your own.
So that's very important to actually understand that.
I like that.
Leading with trust is a more kind, open-minded,
open-hearted way to live.
Yes.
However, I imagine that you probably are an authority
on pattern and behavior.
So is that something that you teach to the new generation
of specifically what to look out for
and not accept as behavior coming at you?
Yes.
Domestic violence is based on power and control.
And so when you teach that behavior,
and behaviors can be learned,
and also, behaviors can be correct.
So when you learn that base, I think it becomes easy
and you could change.
We could actually change society,
knowing the fact that one out of three women
are going to experience domestic abuse in the lifetime.
(Drew sighs)
Every eight seconds a woman gets abused,
children get abused.
And so to me, that breaks my heart.
And I think that education, again, is part of it.
If we teach our children, like I said, sexual education,
we should teach them about healthy relationships.
And that is something very important.
That's part of why I'm doing this documentaries
and I keep doing this documentaries
because it's very important to understand
that abusers are not gonna let go.
But you also said people can change.
Is it more the victim can change or the abuser can change?
If they did the right-
Help.
Yeah.
I mean, when he came out onto the scene,
it was such a bizarre tone.
If you haven't seen the documentary, I urge you to watch it
because it's such an extraordinary journey.
With each part, Jordan Peele,
as he helps tell this narrative, keeps you on the hook
'cause you just can't believe the realities
of this situation.
When John Wayne becomes a porn star
and celebrates this moment
and sort of milks it for money and attention,
how did that make you feel?
It was devastating because, again,
how could this person who have hurt me physically,
emotional, mentally, could be celebrated by society, right?
I did not understand that.
(upbeat pop music)